aber ihr könnt damit bestimmt auf einer
party mal angehen so hey guck mal was
ich kann ich kann hier bei optischen
zoom und eigentlich ist das ja so
schlecht aber wenn man einmal auf 8
rückt dann kann man hier ganz normal
langsam wird's wenn wir ins bettchen
steigen also lasst das jeweilige komisch
angeguckt
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
endlich mal wieder einer neuen folge
minecraft facts ich hab ja auf facebook
in den kommentaren und auf instagram
glaube ich auch angekündigt dass endlich
mal wieder eine folge kommen wird und
doch ist sie diesmal zusammengesteckt
aus euren fakten die ihr wie immer in
die kommentare schreiben könnt und gibt
auch einfach eine bewertung abgeben
wollte ist das öfter kommt zurzeit mache
ich das ja nicht so oft aber wenn ihr
das öfter wollt könnt ihr mir das
einfach anhand von einer bewertung
zeigen und ich würde sagen wir können
eigentlich auch schon direkt anfangen
und zwar fangen wir direkt mit dem
ersten takt an
ich habe mir eine diamant schaufel
geholt ihr könnt auch noch eisen
schaufel nehmen oder eine holz schaufel
oder eine gold schaufel oder eine
steintafel oder eine was gibt's noch ein
doppel keine ahnung
die müsst ihr dann verzaubern ihr könnt
das entweder mit einem amboss machen
oder mit einem zauber tisch errechnen
das einfach mal mit dem amboss tun die
hier rein in dem land hier ein
verzaubertes buch mit glück 3 die nenne
ich jetzt mal einfach wie können wir
dieser nennen
conny hat ein 50 cm alternative schaufel
hier glück drei so ich geh jetzt mal ein
game auf null stellen ich jetzt hier vor
seinem kasten kies und ich verspreche
euch ich werde wenn ich ihn abgebaut
habe 27 flint haben so wir bauen jetzt
mal nach dem abstieg knapp
es kommt immer draußen also wir haben 75
27 flint aus 27 revel bekommt also wenn
ihr eine schaufel auf glück drei
verzaubert kriegt die 1000 prozentig
oder hundertprozentig manager immer in
flint raus wenn ihr gravel abbott und
die autos war einst so kommen wir nun zu
fakt 2 und zwar ist das eine sache die
als ich es gelesen habe dachte ich mir
es ist ja klar aber dann dachte ich mir
der meint also ganze blöcke und dann
dachte mir oh das wusste ich noch nicht
vielleicht wissen dass eine menge von
euch schon
ich wusste es noch nicht deswegen nehme
ich jetzt einfach mal rein und zwar wenn
man hier auf dem zaun läuft kann man ja
ganz normal machen kann man auch darauf
herum hüpfen und zwar ob man kann auch
runterfallen meinsdorf ist damit das
alter ich bin ein sondertreffen zu gehen
man kann hier einfach drauf gehen
das ist relativ witzig weil der zaun ist
als block wenn man hier so guckt ist er
hier zu ändern dann ist hier ein
kompletter block und wenn man auf dem
zaun steht da hatte ich zeige euch das
aussieht dann steht man quasi noch einen
dings höher noch einen halben blog
deswegen kann man da so hochgehen
als wäre das eine treppe hier ich zeige
euch das glück bedeutet also das ist
relativ wird sich das kann man
einerseits hier auf diesen zahlen machen
das kann man auch auf den netto zahlen
machen da kann man einfach überlaufen
also keine sprint taste und das geht bei
diesen komischen türchen hier auch also
relativ kürzlich wusste ich nicht und
auch relativ sinnlos und ich weiß nicht
ob ich das gezeigt aber hey
ist es halt so bitte nicht schlagen so
leute die dritte sache ist unnötig aber
ihr könnt damit bestimmt auf irgendeiner
party man geben so hey guck mal was ich
kann ich kann hier bei optischen zoom
und eigentlich ist das ja so schlecht
aber wenn man einmal acht drückt dann
kann man hier ganz normal langsam wird
es mit mir ins bettchen steigen also
lasst das die valente komisch angeguckt
aber ihr kennt das eben pop tief anderen
wenn ihr ob die vernichtung hat dann
geht euch vergraben alter nennt ist ein
geiler altersgelder händen von berg mit
somit zum schnee links oben drauf das
allgemeine relativ kleine insel vor
allem reisen insel ist jungen dass sich
jetzt erst ist die idee nicht ihr habt
kreativ geil ist ja an alle die wissen
wollen
der startwert uncool also zurück zum
programm erkennt dass der druck noch
tief eindruck steuerung könnt ihr so rum
klettern und ihr drückt einfach einmal
f8 zack und ihr seid im richtigen modus
und ihr könnt ihr noch mal gucken ob das
schaf kommt man an cook wettkampf wer
zuerst weg guckt den alter das blinzelt
sogar wieder geguckt hat verloren
ok also ihr könnt bei auf die
fernsteuerung und dann erst einmal
drücken die so normal so das war's dann
auch wieder mit den minecraft effekt
wenn ihr mehr wollt und wenn ihr
eventuell facts wissen dann schreibt
jetzt mal die kommentare unter dem er
wollte dann möchte ich euch einfach
beten eine bitten nicht beten bitten
deine bewertung abzugeben weil dadurch
ob ihr das gefällt und ob ihr das feiert
und ob ihr mehr von der serie wollte und
dann würde ich sagen sie man ist mal
wieder typisch